Her low freak bitches.
You don't know what the
fuck they're drawing.
You just spout some scribbles on a wall.
You found some of my drawings.
You'd be like,
what?
That guy looked like a d.
There was people that looked like Dick's.
Get that.
You see that hand and that not that one
little that Bolo that this drawing pad.
That's some shit I found
from my high school years.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Just from when I was like 15 that's crazy.
Yeah.
I'll put some skin.
All this shit in there,
but some of it online or you are a hundred
times better than I was and I did it
all the time.
This was like,
this is like from what I was a kid.
It's is a super cat,
Huh?
Oh Shit.
It's like some shit that I drew.
I used to draw a lot and that's bad.
It is loosely used to,
uh,
that's what I really
used to want to be is a,
an artist for a comic book.
So yeah,
1982.
So I guess I was 15 1982
I was eight years old.
I was older than you son.
I love how all your shit's monsters.
Scared of monsters,
man.
Yeah.
Goldilocks and the three bears.
I'm going to have to do something with
these cause I don't really draw anymore.
I don't,
here's what a wolf man.
One I was always until werewolves.
That's why I was so bummed out that uh,
that Benicio Del Toro movie fucking
socks cause it did fucking sack.
Like it didn't happen.
Is that waterfalls?
That's Ninjitsu like you get
this one peeing on the bed,
ping over the bed from the bed.
Ping.
It's like describing are ways to bed.
He's like sitting on the project
that I had to do for school.
I got in trouble all the time because
of was when I was on the wrestling team.
I drew the wrestling logo for our
high school wrestling when um,
when I was as well.
I also drew the logo for our,
um,
our school.
We had to like tee shirts
for Newton south of line.
So I drew the line.
I used to do that too.
I did a word the wording team,
uh,
Kilborne official bungee jumping shirt,
which was a cardinal bungee jumping.
But,
uh,
that's another one that's
from a picture from,
there's an old,
uh,
I think it was long Chaney jr or no,
I don't remember which one,
which Werewolf movie maybe was Oliver.
I don't know which one it was.
Some policy.
Oh,
that's bad ass did stuff.
I was good at looking color.
You've got to be drew.
But uh,
before,
oh,
here's Humpty dumpty,
Humpty dumpty the ax murderer.
I drew a lot of hours.
You put all this shit in your book.
Yeah,
I'll do something with it.
Conan.
That's fun.
That's when I was into
Conan the barbarian now.
So that's amazing.
It's another werewolf.
I was fucking obsessed with werewolves
for whatever fucking gay reason.
That's [inaudible] Harris.
I just,
uh,
I've always loved the wolf man.
And as a result
now werewolf though
wasn't like your father.
I think I was an angry kid and I was
always obsessed with the idea that you
could,
uh,
I think would represented to me was like,
you know,
that you,
you can be calm and normal and then
some shit happens and just right.
And I'll maybe like,
that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to fucking hawk out on
people and turn into a werewolf.
Go mother motherfuckers.
I don't know when you're an angry kid.
Never good.
But I um,
I totally wanted to be
a comic book artist,
but my a high school art
teacher was a Douche bag.
He was just suppressive and
annoying and unhappy and had no joy.
There was no happiness.
This man,
everything was serious.
Like his art was serious and you know,
and he would draw on,
I don't even think he was that talented.
He was like,
he would draw like boring shit,
you know,
he would like draw like pears and stuff,
like a bowl of fruit bowl.
Hey faggot.
You know,
I've got a camera if I want to see fruit,
right,
I'll take a picture of it.
And now let me see it.
You got a photo of Wolverine
fight in Spiderman now,
you know,
to shut the fuck up
because that's what I like.
And he was telling me that what I like
was like juvenile and then it was like
foolish.
And then like my co and I was like,
you're just suppressing what I like,
you know?
I like watching,
you know,
fucking monster movies.
I like reading comic books.
Is there something wrong with that?
It's just an entertainment.
I hate when people pretend that they're
entertainment somehow or another is like
more valid or more sophisticated
just because it's like serious.
You know?
Like people who love serious movies.
Like I'm like,
you know,
comp movies so serious when it was like,
whatever,
man,
are you learning something
when you go to see like,
like,
you know,
some depressing Sean Penn movie.
Are you learning something when you go
to see those movies and everything in
touch with my emotions,
Joe,
it was that river movie.
Whatever the fuck river runs through it.
No,
the,
the Sean Penn won bomb
mystic mystic river.
Is that what it or whatever.
But it was like,
you know,
and everyone's like,
it's such an important film.
Like what?
What,
what's,
what film is important.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're fucking movies,
man.
You go to a movie and enjoy yourself.
You have a good time.
It takes you someplace.
It gives you some thrills,
you know you use a lot of shit,
you don't know what's happening
and things get resolved.
How's this going to,
what's going to go down?
That's all it is.
It's fucking entertainment.
And the idea that your entertainment
because it represents like things that
happen in real life as somehow or
another superior to like superheroes are
monsters.
Like please.
I had a good art teacher that got,
it's funny cause I got,
I'll get C's and D's in every class
because I would sleep except for art,
which I straight a pluses took every
class but my teacher was cool and like a
lot of my paintings I look
back and I'm like wow,
she let me do this.
Like one was called pool table on acid
and she gave me an a minus and it was a
pool table with a monster coming out
of it and everything was melting or
whatnot.
I didn't have to draw for it.
She didn't make me do anything for that.
My teacher to say shit to me.
Like,
you know,
like,
well,
you know what,
if you get a job where you have to
draw a baby for a diaper commercial,
I want to see you draw a
baby for a diaper commercial.
And I'm like,
oh man.
Like why are you fucking telling my sons
do draw a baby for a diaper commercial?
Like is that my future?
Is that w what I have to look forward to?
Yeah.
Drawn diaper ads.
Like he was like,
really?
Like my dream was to do
comic book illustrations and
he was telling me basically
you need to have skills because you're
not going to reach those dreams and what
if you have a job that's just you as
an illustrator doing boring stuff,
but you have to drop boring stuff.
And I was like,
you fucking buzzkill,
you know?
And this guy was just a dumpy,
physically out of shape,
unhealthy person.
And he was just just
depressed all the time.
And so I killed my,
effectively,
I went,
I only went for two years,
uh,
our,
our class,
I believe it was 14 and 15.
I think by the time I went into
my junior year of high school,
I think I said,
fuck that guy.
I'm tired of this.
Yeah.
It's annoying.
So I just drew on my own from then
on and that effectively killed my,
my wanting to,
uh,
go to school for art.
I had to like was looking at
our colleges and shit and had a,
you know,
scholarships lined up and trying
to figure out where to go.
So like the only thing I had a chance
of getting any sort of scholarship,
then meanwhile it's just
teachers and you know,
when you don't realize what a gigantic
fucking effect having a good or a shitty
teacher can have on yeah.
But they're,
you know,
they're cutting their
salaries over and over again.
I just saw it.
They're cutting it again.
Yeah.
And I think teachers should be one
of the most important things ever.
You know,
like up there with doctors and
stuff that's junk can't tick.
Yeah.
Amazing how we were so short and when it
comes to excited when it comes to that.
Yeah.
What is that you're raising
the child from the beginning.
That should be the most important thing.
Huge people that can
influence your children.
And,
and people that say mean Shit.
Like I will never forget I had a math
teacher in high school who was just
fucking boring and the class was boring
and she was this black lady who had a
black accent.
Like she would mispronounce
words all the time.
She had terrible grammar and yet she
would like shit all over you if you didn't
understand her,
her,
her math problems.
And she,
uh,
was in there doing her math problem and
I was bored and I was like drawing or
something.
And usually that's what I did in class.
I would draw on my notebooks
or something and she goes,
she looks up and she sees
me not paying attention.
So she goes,
Mr Rogan,
would you like to come up here and do
both of these problems for the class?
And I said,
you want me to do both of those problems?
Everybody started fucking how Olin.
And so she said,
go down to the Dean's office right now.
I said,
okay,
but when I get back,
I'm going to do both of those problems.
And everybody was laughing.
She goes,
go ahead,
laugh and Mr Wogan,
Mr welcome ain't going nowhere.
He's going nowhere in life.
And I'm like,
at least I know how to say,
get out of my classroom.
And she kicked me out of that.
So long as that was like the beginning
of my time as a standup comedian because
I felt like I was defending myself.
Like I wasn't doing anything to you.
I was just sitting there
scribbling in my notebook,
you know?
I just wasn't paying attention because
I was bored out of my fucking head and I
had problems with authority,
but she just liked to be the the lady
to call on you if you ain't paying
attention,
you know,
like she would,
she would get mad.
But I mean,
meanwhile this fucking
bitch couldn't even speak.
Right.
She said both.
Would you like to come up here and be,
do both of them?
I will never forget it.
It's like in my mind it's like a movie
playing out because the anger in my head
that this fucking dummy was trying to
make me look dumb in front of everybody
just cause I was scribbling and I
wasn't paying attention to your,
my,
my opinion on math was always like,
okay,
math is very essential,
but don't you have calculators now we do
and isn't there like an endless supply
of batteries?
There is done,
right?
Like I'm done.
I've,
there's only a finite amount of things
to pay attention to in the day and I
don't give a fuck about these wacky
equations that you're making me solve and
figure out.
I know how to add.
I know how to divide.
I know how to multiply.
Like is it or are we done here?
Do I have to keep going?
Is this really gonna you're,
you're making me be a fucking square peg
and fit into your fucking round hole.
You know?
It's like I'm not,
I don't want to do what you want me to do.
Like this is nonsense.
It's weird nowadays.
I can't even imagine going to school
with Google because then I'd be like,
no,
I don't want to learn it.
I could just search it if I need it.
I don't get what you,
that was a problem.
I used to watch a lot of documentaries
even when I was a kid and I got in
trouble again.
Like people are still like your
comedian where your class clown.
Like I was not really class clown.
What I used to do though is draw a
lot of cartoons about our teachers,
like getting involved,
doing shit.
And we had this one teacher
that was really annoying,
Mr Hallman and h o l m a n very serious,
but he was wrong about a lot of shit.
And I was,
you know,
I was fucking 15 years old and uh,
I was,
uh,
in class and I was again
bored out of my fucking mind.
He had a science class but at least
science classes a little more interesting.
And he started going on about Lake Erie.
Lake Erie is a dead
lake and this and that.
And you started talking about all the
pollution that's involved in Lake Erie.
And I said,
well actually I just saw a
documentary that was on PBS.
It was talking about the
resurgence of Lake Erie,
about how leaky or they've worked very
hard to filter out the water and they've
done all these different things to cut
down on the pollutants and they've seen a
resurgence and,
and the the fish population.
And he got all fucking mad at me.
And I was like,
have you seen this documentary?
He goes,
no,
this is not true.
And I'm like,
my,
I know it's not true.
It's on PBS.
I watched it last night,
right?
I'm like,
aw man.
All right,
so you're just like them.
So the next time we're in class,
um,
he had like these things that would
pull down like projection screens and I
pulled the projection screens
up and I drew cartoons of him
and then I pulled the
projection down and covered him.
So he wants to draw on the chalkboard.
And as he pulled the chalkboard up,
there's all these fucking cartoons ahead,
like saying wacky shit.
And he had this thing that he would do,
like who would do this,
this crazy thing with his hands.
We would move his hands like this.
And then I have this other teacher,
Mr. White,
and he was only like five foot two.
So I drew him all the time,
but every time I drew them I
drew him standing on something,
standing on a box or standing,
got a chair,
a standing guy.
It's doable.
And I drew a just like him.
It's so funny.
Did
and I had a one in
anthropology teacher who,
uh,
was obsessed with Jane
Goodall and the monkeys.
You know,
Jane Goodall lived live with chimpanzees.
So I drew this one kid who was his
football player who was a nice kid,
but he was always kissing her ass cause
he wanted her to like him so he could
get better grades.
So I drew him,
banging her and uh,
like it was like and look like her.
It looked like him and
I drew him bagging her,
say,
you know,
she was like,
oh,
give it to me monkeys.
Pass it around the class.
You know,
like I got suspended on two separate
occasions for drawing cartoons.
That's fine.
I got sent home for time.
That's the only thing I would
normally get in trouble for him.
I did the same things,
but with overhead projectors,
I was like dead some penises,
there's an Indian guy in our class.
I always make fun of his carts because
he had really bad farts and then one time
they pulled the whole class
out and they're were like,
all right.
Uh,
Omar has really bad gas because of his
diet and it's not funny and if you guys
make fun of it anymore,
you guys are all gonna be in trouble.
I remember the speech.
So of course then I only drew Omar for
the rest of the year after all this
Indian guy pardon?
On people and stuff like that.
How ridiculous is that you,
you tell them kids not to make
fun of farts cause it's not fun.
I know.
How disingenuous is that.
You cannot tell someone
that farts are funny.
As soon as you say farts are funny,
I'm not listening to you.
Right?
Because you're not being honest.
Yeah.
You could say farts don't smell.
Can you imagine if he love smog farts?
This,
the people that do this,
like fart porn.
Have you ever seen far?
You're right as far porn where dudes get
their head right and gross faces in the
growth part in their mouths.
God,
and get such a hard on now.
Okay.
[inaudible].